[Musique]
je suis monsieur barnabé philippins j'ai
une entreprise ion de verre
je suis créateur un métier d'art
tourneur sur pierre et bois et
j'habite en pleine campagne donc pour le
confinement c'est pas mal
[Musique]
dans deux mois c'est des vacances
forcées tu vois donc c'est un peu
compliqué hein
au départ bon plein de choses à faire
chez moi
jamais le temps de faire à droite à
gauche aujourd'hui j'ai le temps de
faire tout ça plus un peu de glandouille
des balades
je suis pas à plaindre du tout
économiquement pour l'instant ça passe
un petit peu parce qu'il est tout petit
frère mon proprio est super gentil a
prié le loyer donc si ça dure pas
ça va aller
c'est la reprise qui fait flipper
comportement des gens ils vont pas aller
1 demain
allez c'est la teuf et on va consommer
comme un envie de se faire plaisir je
crois pas
après un retour durable si ça ça se vend
pas c'est plus négatif pour le mont
royal de créer pour quelque chose qu'on
sais pas dans combien ça besoin que de
passer à autre chose pour mieux rentrer
tempe